swedish home style cooking with a
sophisticated twist that's frederick
anders passion the chef uses all kinds
of fresh herbs to put a special spin on
traditional ingredients
like veal
and asparagus
and to garnish desserts like rhubarb
sorbet
around 20 different herbs are used in
his kitchen including verbena cress and
thai lemon basil
the restaurant provent swears by fresh
ingredients and most products are
delivered every morning
it's good it tastes good
number f
there's nothing like a fresh herb or a
really fresh salad because you can feel
i mean if it's
newly picked or really fresh then you
can feel the
would sound cliche to say that you can
feel the sunlight but then you can feel
the green in it always that's where you
can really feel it when it's still taste
chlorophyll
then it's fresh
frederick sources many of his
ingredients from the company orton novo
a 45-minute drive from stockholm they
grow herbs and salads in huge
greenhouses all year round here alone
there are seven different types of basil
but also red
and yellow charred
two hundred thousand plants leave the
facility every week
and they're sent to restaurants across
the whole of sweden
when i began this in 88
we
in sweden more or less there were only
three
traditional fresh herbs and that was
the chives parsley and the deal
and
what they have been interested in is is
more more you know what is a little bit
different what is it what is special and
what can be um
you know what can add something to the
kitchen i think
so we have about 50 different varieties
and
the more the special more they are
interesting to the chefs
today frederick is making the most of
this wide variety to update a
traditional swedish dish fresh pike
dumplings with beetroot for the
dumplings we're using the ground the
ground pike
we're using salt
using a little bit of the whipped cream
and also
eggs
and with the dumplings we're going to
serve them with our bread beets fresh
red beets which we cook
with
a little bit of cumin water sugar and
salt
he mixes 600 grams of fresh pike
together with a pinch of salt and 500
grams of cream in a food processor until
the mixture is stiff
you have to be careful
not to not to mix it too long or not too
slow because it's it has to stick
together and if you mix it too long or
if you are
if you have it's too warm or something
then it can split then the ground and
the cream doesn't go together
form the mixture into dumplings with a
spoon and place them into water just
below the boil
so then we cook them three minutes turn
them over so you get them on the other
side as well and another three minute
three minutes on the other side
frederick mixes the beetroot together
with cumin seeds salt and a splash of
vinegar
he tests with a sharp prong to see
whether they're ready
and they are
we eat a lot of beets and root
vegetables so it's very that's very
traditional because that's what you can
grow
not all year round but you can grow it
and you can keep it in storage for the
winter because we have such
cold climates
the pike dumplings with beetroot are
served with a hollandaise sauce and
fresh herbs
red chard dill and watercress not only
enhance the flavor but they make the
dish more appealing to the eye
you